hi my name is masali kanekil i'm from
boxing research center niaid
national institutes of health and thank
you for guys are for giving me an
opportunity to present our work
in this microbiology culture week so
today i'm going to talk about
nanoparticle-based next-generation
infant vaccines
so before we start uh this is my public
disclosure statement
and i want to start with this slide
highlighting some of the technology
breakthroughs in the mid century
and their evolution afterwards so
showing on the left
is a bus microwave uh developed
in 1947 it is called radar range
it is six feet tall eight hundred pounds
and cost more than fifty thousand
dollars around the same time
they uh stud they were paying for
vaccines
using embryonic eggs as shown here in
the picture
is our one the picture from
40s i think uh infecting and dna with
eggs within the enterprises
and as you all know that microwave today
is less than one foot tall less than 20
pounds
and cost less than 50 but today
still the influenza vaccine production
is heavily relying on
embryonic egg and the technology
developed over 75 years ago so we
believe that technology can reversionize
the influence of boxing
in the near future so here are the
technology focus of the brc influencer
boxing program
so we have five beads so the first thing
is discovery
so this is uh by isolating and
characterizing
molecular antibodies to influence the
bust
and hopefully to identify the parasites
of vulnerability
that informs vaccine design so the
second is the design
so we are heavy and heavy on the
structure based on structured guided
protein engineering
for vaccine immunogen as well as
research tools
and third one is display so this is
um something that we are
investing a lot of time and efforts in
these years
uh to find the best format to display
antigens
to immune system so we use both natural
and designed nanoparticle platforms to
do that
and the fourth one is the delivery so
this is um
traditionally our vaccine is protein
based
but now you know that other options such
as messenger rna
it's a pretty attractive tool for
vaccine delivery
so that is also in consideration
aj is another one and also
uh uh lives of immunization
the fifth d is the detection so here
are developing assays and tools for
specific neurological
endpoints so this includes the precise
psychological assays on single cell
phonics
to identify and to delineate immune
responses to inference vaccine
so influenza viruses uh
two major uh proteins on the surface two
of them are the glycoproteins in the
surface
so one is shown in blue here is the
hemorrhaging
a and another one is called n a so the
neural net
is so for the sake of time i don't go
through the in a base design
but this is something uh
are um in in the focusing these days
um but ha is the major
uh vaccine induced uh immune response
target
so the aka is a homophilic protein which
has
structurally defined head domain and
stem domains
so the head domain is is
it's a hypervariable domain of aha so
which differs not strained by strain
but it's immunodominant so it's a very
major genetic protein
and the stem domain in contrast is a
highly conserved domain
which uh increase the virus
fusion machinery
so this domain is uh usually you know
sardonium
but antibody against this domain can be
very broadly closely active so we have
uh
three different approaches and three
different antigens
so we made a nanoparticle vaccines
of using the receptor binding domain
which is a part of the head
so by displaying them as a mosaic array
on the nanoparticle shown here on the
top the mosaic arbitrary particle
and shown in the middle is the h a
nanoparticle which displays a triangle
extra domain of hemorrhaging on the
surface of self-assembling nanoparticles
so this self-assembly now particle is
the basis for
our next generation vaccine and it can
mount
the virus to try and make glycoproteins
on the surface
the bottom here is say are called aj
stem nanoparticles
so this is this spraying instead of
fluorinated
fiber it's displaying engineered
stereo stim nano particles or stem
trimers on the surface
so each have different goals to achieve
a better protection against
ever-changing effects viruses so the
first approach
the mosaic are the nanoparticles is
avoiding
adornments so this is displaying
multiple launching
variants at the same time that
promote the immune system to recognize
the conserved domain
among the displayed antigens so this
will
be a good way to avoid immune dominance
and also
uh overcome the ancient competition
between
antigens so the h a nanoparticle is this
is
this is a highly immediate form so we
can generate
a immune response very potent immune
response to the aha
so by doing this way we can quickly
generate vaccine
and hopefully we can accumulate the
breast by combining multiple different
hnr particles
so the stem nanoparticles are displaying
the conserved domain of
of aha so the goal is to target the
immune system
to generate antibodies and plants that
are
of the virus in the later of today's
talk i'm going through
some new technologies uh including this
mosaic hmi particle
so which have a full-length h-a timer on
the surface
of nanoparticles but multiple different
kinds
of aha at the same time
so starting with this uh self-assembly
nanoparticle platform we developed
um now like several several years ago
using these heterobacter pyramid-based
uh nanoparticles
so this forms a octahedral particle with
the 24
identical subunits so
this platform is assembling
in vivo which means upon biosynthesis of
the protein they
spontaneously assemble into a particle
by using this platform
we and others have have been very
successful
for generating vaccine candidates not
only
against the intense virus but also
against hyperspires
epstein-barr rsv and more recently
lyme disease so but we focus more uh
now today on the influence bars so i'm
gonna show you
a couple of progress that we made in the
last
several years so first the aha
nanoparticles we reported in 2013
about the development of the vaccine in
2017
we initiated the human phase one
clinical trial with the prototype
again our particle vaccine and now
the trial is fully enrolled and we
almost finished on isis
so we we are hoping to to report
uh the results from the trial soon
and a few years after we developed the
stabilized stem
nanoparticles using the group one h1
subtype aj so um
this vaccine generate a broadly
cross-reactive
stem diaphragmatic responses that is
what
that's uh that is protective against
virus changes in animal models
so we initiated the phase one clinical
trials at vlc
in 2019 and
[Music]
we still the trial is still ongoing
but um hopefully we can
we can report the results from the trial
and even soon
uh so shortly after the group one
human trials began we
published the paper about group 2ha stem
nanoparticles
the group 2 stem nanoparticles are not
very easy
to make so at the brc
uh we spent several years to design and
optimize
the stabilized stem immunogen for the
group 2ha
and shown here is is um
the cartoon showing all the mutations we
made to stabilize that
ha stem domain from the good to
uh in in to our intact training
structure but we have made uh
the stabilized dha and successfully
displayed on the
nanoparticles shown in here on the
bottom is the criterium structure of
of the stem nanoparticles
of the h10 so these uh
group two stamina particles are highly
protective against
heterosexual group two virus challenges
in animal model
so shown here on the right is that h10
based stem nanoparticle
immunized mice challenged with different
group 2 viruses including h3 and 2h7 and
9
in addition to h10na which is the
homologous virus
shown here on the bottom is the empty
nanoparticle immunized control
so these h10 nanoparticles are
now being produced at the brc
for intended office one clinical trials
starting this year
so now switching here to a mosaic harvd
nanoparticle
which is uh recently published
i don't want to spend too much time on
this because it's published
but let me uh introduce this uh concept
about mosaic and child display
so shown here on the left
this is a very simplified view when the
immune system
encounters the particulate antigen
including viruses and vaccines
so each files even with the highly
heterogeneous hiv or influenza virus
each billion have only one antigenic
type on the surface
so shown here depicted as a blue antigen
so each particular antigen when
encounters immune system
being recognized by a b cells with the
coordinate pcr
on the surface so shown here
in the middle is the blue antigen
specific pieces which is recognizing the
blue angiogen
on the particle at the same time
we also have a subset of pieces
that can recognize not only blue but
brew and some other antigens
which is also present but it's um
it's not completed by the blue specific
response but we hypothesize that
uh if we introduce something
um non-natural heterogeneous nitrogen
with multiple different ancient variants
on the surface
that kind of particles may interact
very differently with the immune system
compared to homogeneous antigens
so these uh heterogeneous mosaic
antigens
are having multiple different types of
variants on the surface of the particle
so this case the blue specific pieces
have a difficult time to recognize it
because the blue antigen on the surface
of these mosaic particles
are diluted and it's
the bcr on these pieces can recognize
only blue ones
but instead uh
these particles are will be very
recognized by the cross reactive pieces
shown here in the bottom with the orange
vcr
so these b cells can recognize not only
blue but
also cyan red green and yellow for
instance
so these are these pieces
have now better opportunity to be
expanded
propagated and also uh contribute to to
the
uh new response so this is our
hypothesis and to
to test this hypothesis we we developed
now particle vaccines using uh
harbd so which is highly divergent
portion of the hea so shown on the left
is monotypic display
with only single ancient type on the
surface
on the right is a mosaic display
with multiple different ancient types
launching
variants on the surface of a single
nanoparticle
so we can control this uh particular
density and
heterogeneity of antigens by design
so the construct design as i said using
harvd
genetically refused to accurate in
subunit monomer
and then it self-assembles into 24
minute particles
so we pick a multiple different strains
of hgrbd and make nanoparticles
in individually presenting one nunchang
type
or as a mosaic display on the right
so the odd mixture is a multiple
different particles
each present single enchanted type
so as you can see if you measured an
immune response against the blue on
sample for
for for instance if you give other
mixture
of multiple different particles as you
increase the biology
of antigen
you are getting a reduced response to
the glue
in contrast on the right hand side if
you present the same
uh antigen in the mosaic ancient array
you don't see that kind of decreased
response to
the blue and shin for instance so
this is a kind of new way
to to overcome this unchanged
competition
between the antigens by co-displaying
multiple variants at the same time
so even more strikingly when we immunize
uh the particles either
cocktail mosaic or the sequential
vaccination
where we immunize
one or two particles at the time but
each time
the animals see the different particles
so in that case
um we expect the sequential vaccination
also accumulate the breath
but on the mosaic nanoparticle
outperforms
either both the odd mixture of multiple
different particles
or the sequential vaccination
so shown here on the right is the uh
global gmt
of uh five different viruses
tested so the mosaic vaccination
is outperforming other vaccination
measurement
so to confirm that we are
selecting uh the b cells but cross
recognizing
or cross reactive to multiple different
antigens
we isolated a monoclonal antibody from
the mice mouse immunized with mosaic rb
nanoparticles so shown here on the left
is one of the example
of 1v6 employee in complex with ha
timer as you can see the articulation
here in the core
car is recognizing aj head
the recognition of the aha is uh
the site is different from the cytocast
binding site
which is shown here on in asterisk
so that the 401 b6 binding side
is also different from the classically
defined and chunk size
in the aging head and
now the antigenic site recognized by
41.6 is called
other patch of aha and this is highly
conserved among
different h1 subtype
viruses so indeed when we test
on a multiple different h1n1 viruses
in the shield-wire symmetrization are
saying 401d6 neutralize
all of them also this antibody
is cross-reactive and used by the mosaic
rdb menopause and this is our working
model of promoting one part through
vaccine
so when you immunize when you stimulate
the immune system with the homophobic
stimuli
shown in gray you and the
immune population reacting with this
gray antigen
and most of them are monospecific
but when you stimulate the immune system
with the head of
a heterotypic steroid the mosaic antigen
you you have much better chance to erase
it
across the active b cells by by this
type of
stimulation so that's the basis of
the mosaic and gender spray and move on
to the next one so we
have been uh playing a lot with this
ferritin nanoparticle platform
but also exploring other platforms
including bermuda and synthase
capsule or even the byte component
uh insect creating platform
but um there are
more flexible and advanced nanoparticle
platform out there
so we started collaboration with the
institute for
protein design at the university of
washington
especially the new kings group in
institute
who is pioneering this area of making
those uh design surface membrane
particles
so the um
so we have been working together for
years
uh now to design a new influence on
nanoparticle vaccine using his platform
so his platform is is made of shown here
is the two component nanoparticles
means that uh two different subunits
make
one particle so shown here in blue is
making primer
and grades making pentamers
and when you mix them together it forms
a lot of
because they made a specific interface
between the primer and pantomime that
promote the surface memory of of those
two
two subunits so this
design principal
is it's it's very uh precise and
controllable
so the beauty is
is one of the beauty
of of the system is is that you can make
uh
pantomimers and primers in the separate
reaction
so you can prepare your your antigens in
the different expression system for
instance
or different reactions and
once you purify the materials you just
simply mix them together to make
particles and this is this is a dear
platform to make
a controllable way of mosaic display
so we picked uh we we chose one of one
of
uh the nanoparticle platform which has
been developed by the university of
washington
have um
made of primer and pantomime so in this
case the pantomime is coming from
yeast and primaries are heavily designed
by the protein
engineering suite contour
so the nanoparticle called i53 dn5
means it's
made of primer and pentamer and trimer
shown here in
light blue is designed
[Music]
optimized for ancient display the
primary conchain display
so the the small blue dot here is the
entireness of the protein
so which is located near the
straightforward axis and then
co-localized together in the
cross-proximity
to accommodate the trimet protein fusion
so but when you mix uh this primer and
pentamer
uh it forms another part spectral
nanoparticles
and shown here is native stain em
picture of the particles
and as you can see the construction
image on the bottom
left uh it's uh the design is
very accurate and it produces
a very homogeneous anal quality
on assembly reaction
so we use this i53bn5 platform
to display h a and change from influence
bars so
in principle we can we can display up to
20 different timers per particle
but uh shown here as an example at the
bottom
is the h a nanoparticle with the h a the
single aha
and the cryonium reconstruction image
showing here
is the nanoparticle with the spikes
protruding from the core
and it's resembling the motor and when
we isolate the spike density from the
particle and then we construct based on
on the spike based on on the logarithms
reconstruction
h a displayed on the particle is very
intact and you can see the shape of the
aha and you can see
all the genetic sites that consumers and
the nhs thing is available
so this is ideal uh platform to display
the viral antigens especially in this
case nha
so we move forward with this platform
and then
create uh the vaccine candidate
so we chose uh four different ahas to be
present
on the particle because these four are
identical strains that
are in
of the commercial uh influence vaccine
of 2017
so which has h1 h3
and two inference bhas so we need two
preparations so top here uh we call
tactile
i53bn5 so each particle present
one munching type for instance the red
one
that is nanoparticle presenting h1
ha on the red one and h3hm blue one and
so on
and the second preparation we made is
the a quarter event mosaic
nanoparticle using the same component
but uh core assembled into a single
particles
so each part will have has all
four has on the surface by doing the
negative stain em analysis you can
clearly see those
were formed core with protruding spikes
projecting outward for those hm
nanoparticles
and uh we did the immunology uh
immunogenicity study
by using three different animal models
my spirits and human primates
and these are the three vaccine
vaccines that we used in the study so
the first one
is qid so this is a commercially
influenced vaccine from 2017-18
season and the cocktail vaccine in the
middle
is the cocktail formulation that i i
just described
in the mosaic on the right
one has been vaccinated uh three times
and then uh we measured the
anterior responses up in the vaccination
so here is the hemorrhagination
inhibition tighter
after vaccination so shown
here is the vaccine matched and slightly
mismatched in from the b
responses in mice and pets
and human primates as you can see the
immune responses
are induced by the aging nanoparticles
as
good as commercial vaccine and sometimes
you see a slightly better response
by the hnr qualities
and here is the micro neutralization
tighter
which um a little bit more sensitive
i'll say because you can
uh detect not only their uh
hema origination inhibition activity but
also
a fusion inhibition elsewhere so the
stem
directed anterior response can be
measured in the micrometer
so in this case again we see
the past anterior response
neutralizing response against
vaccine-matched
viruses in all three angle models
and a few cases we see statistically
higher responses by
aj nanoparticles so
we are more interested to know about
the breadth of the response so showing
here
is the phytogenetic three of h1n1
vials the aha sequences
on the left and the pyrogenic three of
h3 sequences on the right
so we picked our historical strains
from both h1 and h3 3
and then analyze the neutrogena
neutralizing response against those
viruses
so as you can see the aha nanoparticle
immunized
animals shown here in blue and red
are showing slightly but
a higher on interesting neutralizing
tighter against those drifted viruses
and then the commercial vaccines
so more importantly when these immunized
animals are charged with the
heterologous h1n1 or
significantly depressing h3n2 virus
we see a better protection provided by
the aha
nanoparticle vaccination compared to
a qiv vaccination
so not only the direct exchange we are
most interested to know about
heteroseptic responses
by those vaccines so we pick a couple
different h
uh uh aha from both group one
and group two influence a viruses
so again the h1 and the h3
are included in the vaccine but nothing
else is included in the vaccine
so when you look at h5 and h6 response
from group 1
you see a higher overall mean responses
with their agent or particular
vaccinations compared to a qab
vaccination
and same story is true for a uh group
2has
we tested age 7 and age 10 and we see
a significantly higher anterior
responses against those two
heteroseptic has but importantly these
these heterosceptic bars are
heterozygous
responses are functional and providing
protection
in animal models so here we vaccinated
mice and challenged with either h5n1 on
top
or h7n9 bars on the bottom so you can
see
the uh aha nanoparticle immunized mice
are protected from from death
in this vaccination or in this challenge
but the commercial vaccine provides none
or very weak protection against the
requires changes
and the trends are the same for the
thirds
so we challenge with h5 and h7
and we see a better survivor that's
where was a lower
viral load in the lung after challenge
in non-human primates we took a slightly
different approach
so we purified our polychronol ig
immunoglobulin after vaccination and
those purified immunoglobulins
we possibly transferred into recipient
mice
and then challenged with the h5n1
or the h7n9 and you can clearly see that
hml body could derive the igg
provides more uh concrete protection
against those
heterosceptic viruses so suggesting that
protection we are seeing
on the heterosexual protection you're
seeing is uh
remediated and the the seasonal
vaccine component is sufficient to
induce these
heterosceptic
immune response so to confirm that our
heteroseptic
responses we have seen is directing to
the stem
of the aha and and again the aha stem
domain is highly consoled across
different subtypes
so we pick um we we
use the stem on the protein which is
developed at the brc
by protein engineering so you use both
h1 or the h3 stem only protein to
to detect the stem directed responses
so as you can see in all three animal
models we detect much higher
android responses against the stem
by aging by the vaccinations compared to
the commercial vaccine
and it's most strikingly when we purify
the polycarbonate igg from from
non-human primates
and they actually visualize with the
cryo-em
the technique called implant so that
it stops mopping by questionnaire
spectrum microscopy
uh so we identified uh two major classes
of monthly that recognize h5ha in those
portfolio igg
and one of them strikingly similar to a
human
antibody called mary852 so which is
uh one of the best monthly known so far
against influenced viruses
so this is uh suggesting that non-human
primates upon vaccination
with a general particle can generate uh
globally cross-reactive stem directed
antler responses start designing
the human responses and strikingly when
we
quantify the classes of antibody bound
to the aj
the more gear by mpem we see a
more diverse population
of antibody crisis against homologous
assumption h1 on the left
in the pie chart but when you look at
the h5
substrate we only see the stem directed
until these
so suggesting that stem domain
[Music]
is uh highly accessible in in the
vaccine
and immunogenic
uh so to summarize uh the first part
i'm showing that surface membrane on
nanoparticles
are powerful and highly physical vaccine
platforms
and fasting human clinical studies prove
that the nanoparticle vaccines
are safe and very tolerated
and mosaic and i introduced the mosaic
nanoparticle
display which invariant that can
subworth
medium dominance of strength [ __ ]
responses
uh by providing a very advantage to
cross-reactive b cells
in the second part i i introduced the
designed
two-component nanoparticle platform that
um
can uh that allow us to do the in vitro
assembly reaction
of nanoparticle with programmable
stoichiometry so this is
extremely useful uh for for the design
ability of the vaccine
and using this platform we made a
quadrivalent hm nanoparticles
that are highly energetic in mysteries
and non-human primates
in these nanoparticles it is important
head directed neutralizing anterior
responses
as well as probably cross reactive stem
directed protective contour responses
and based on this result we uh the vrc
has initiated the gmt manufacturing of
the caller advantage in our particles
and for the intended phase one clinical
trials
in 2021 and if you want to know more
about the colored vintage in our
particle
we have a preprint up in the bio archive
so with that um we
see the next generation nanoparticle
based vaccines i can
i can do the uh simple multiple display
of antigens that can facilitate
a better immune recognition
as whereas the mosaic display which
will be selectively inducing
cross-reactive pieces
and it's a better way to avoid
engineering competition
in your dominance and also
we are exploring the options to
incorporating
uh immunomodular free molecules
in in the vaccine so in your tithing
near potentiation
and surplus planting and importantly on
our nanoparticle designs design
all based on the genetic fusion so it's
uh
it's compatible with the genetic
delivery such as
messenger and a vaccine
with that i'd like to thank to many
people involved in these studies
especially for bonnie graham who
directs the influencer program at the
brc
and and in the clinical trial program
who let's release the clinical trials of
those uh crucial principle nanoparticle
vaccines
and for the second part uh the cholera
advantage in our particles
the project was uh led by
say hamburger bottom from a group and
daniel eris from near king's group so
again
that project was very close
collaboration with new kings lab
at the institute for protein design at
the university of washington
and it was my pleasure to do the work
with them so
we have uh a lot more uh
to report in the future so
[Music]
i'm very excited so i will stop here
and thank you very much for your
attention